jetzt blicken wir erst mal nach münchen
denn hier ist heute eine bombe
explodiert und zwar mitten in der stadt
direkt am hauptbahnhof es war eine 250
kilo bombe aus dem zweiten weltkrieg
fast 80 jahre lang hat sie still dort
herumgelegen heute nachmittag also ist
sie plötzlich hoch gegangen und zwar mit
einer gewaltigen explosion
und unsere kollegen elli kühlen die
steht jetzt genau dort wo diese
weltkriegs bombe explodiert ist nelly
warum ist das jetzt passiert was ist da
genau passiert
ja tatsächlich ist heute eine bombe in
münchen explodiert genau in der
innenstadt hier an der
donnersbergerbrücke es handelt sich
dabei um bauarbeiten der deutschen bahn
es soll eine zweite stammstrecke der s
bahn errichtet werden und bei diesem
bauarbeiten sind bauarbeiter bei
bohrungen auf diese vermeintliche
fliegerbombe auf die fliegerbombe
gestoßen und die bombe ist detoniert das
ist aktuell passiert
also man hört ja da aus münchen das hat
alles gewackelt sollen die gewaltige
druckwelle gegeben haben jeder der heute
nachmittag am bahnhof war hat das gehört
hat das mitbekommen hat sich erschreckt
was genau ist passiert gibt es verletzte
dort
genau die trümmerteile sind hunderte
meter geflogen
den knall hat mein kilometerweise noch
gehört und leider gibt es vier verletzte
personen eine davon schwer verletzt dass
es einer der bauarbeiter der hier an
dieser neuen stammstrecke gearbeitet hat
und ihm musste ein teil seines beines
amputiert werden ein anderer bauarbeiter
saß in seinem bagger und diese große
maschine hat wahrscheinlich sein leben
gerettet dann weil er in diesem bagger
saß hat er die explosion überlebt aber
auch er ist verletzt dann ist noch ein
dritter bauarbeiter verletzt und ein
security mitarbeiter also wir haben vier
verletzte und einen schwerverletzten
also es gibt sogar noch ein ganz
bisschen glück im unglück durch diesen
möglicherweise lebensrettenden baggern
ähnlich wir haben das bild dort gerade
von der unglücksstelle gesehen aber wir
fragen uns trotzdem hier im studio fehle
auch wie kann das passieren also immer
wieder tauchen ja diese fliegerbomben
auf in allen großstädten überall vor
allen dingen auch hier natürlich in
berlin immer wieder wird dann evakuiert
zur sicherheit aber man weiß nach ein
paar stunden ist das vorbei hier war es
nicht so warum konnte das passieren hat
man nicht genügend vorsicht walten
lassen
diese frage beschäftigt hier gerade alle
auch im minister joachim herrmann war
heute vor ort hat sich ein bild gemacht
und er hat ganz klar gesagt es muss
jetzt ermittelt werden warum wurde diese
bombe nicht schon zuvor entdeckt und man
muss auch sagen die donnersberger brücke
ist nur eine s-bahn-station vom
hauptbahnhof in münchen entfernt und das
areal rund und im hauptbahnhof ist ein
sogenanntes verdachts areal war im
zweiten weltkrieg hier wahnsinnig viele
bomben runtergekommen sind man weiß also
rund um den hauptbahnhof in münchen
liegen viele viele bomben versteckt vom
zweiten weltkrieg jetzt muss aber
geklärt werden ist auch dieses unfalls
ort wo heute die bombe explodiert ist
ist das auch noch das verdachts areal
und wenn ja wurde hier überhaupt geprüft
oder wurde ihr gewusst das ist jetzt die
frage die in den kommenden tagen die
ermittler beschäftigen wird
nelly dankeschön für den moment für
diese ganz aktuellen informationen vom
ort der explosion in der münchner
innenstadt
und jetzt wollen wir mal zur diplom
geophysiker und kampfmittelräumer
rüdiger schmidt seiten der ist nämlich
seit über 30 jahren tätig für eine firma
für kampfmittel bergung er betreibt
diese firma auch und münchen ist ja nun
im gebet in dem immer wieder pfleger
bomben hochgehen und gefunden werden
wieso kann man das nicht vorher sagen
man weiß ja ungefähr wo diese bomben
runtergegangen sind
ja es sind nervös also man hat alliierte
doch bildauswertung um bestimmte
bombenverdachts gebiete zu untersuchen
und die einzugrenzen jedoch haben sie
aufgrund von wolken beziehungsweise
schlechten sichtbedingungen keine
hundertprozentige genauigkeit und
aussagekraft aus dem grunde macht man
also eine systematische kontrollen
erkundung in solchen verdachts gebieten
davor man dort die bauarbeiten
durchführt wir haben gerade kurz gesehen
wo diese hotspots sozusagen sind wo
besonders viele fliegerbomben in
deutschland noch liegen oder vermutet
werden jetzt habe ich gerade schon
gesagt normalerweise ist es so ständig
im radio hier in berlin auch diese
ankündigung der wird wieder geräumt dann
wird das umfeld dort evakuiert und nach
paar stunden heißt es dann eben wieder
alles okay alles geschafft wenn sie die
informationen jetzt aus münchen sammeln
was ist ihr eindruck warum das da so
gründlich schiefgegangen ist
also grundsätzlich
werden komplett erkundungsmaßnahmen
durchgeführt es kann natürlich sein dass
diese
untersuchungen leute nicht aussagefähig
genügend waren oder dass sie vielleicht
auch unterlassen worden sind oder dass
die baufirma trotzdem gebaut hat ich
weiß es nicht ich nehme ich dazu auch
nicht im detail äußern ohne eine
aktenlage zu haben in der regel ist es
so dass man im bahnbereich
untersuchungen macht man
von raster bohrungen abgeteuft in denen
werden gegen magnetische messungen
durchgeführt
und wo dort anomalien festgestellt
werden klebt man vorsichtig nach oder
macht haftungen um soll die kampfmittel
zu entschärfen
dort wo bogen nicht gehen gibt es andere
verfahren im gleisbereich wird zeigt was
die rada eingesetzt die klassischen
elektromagnetik verfahren und
geomagnetik verfahren gehen dort leider
nicht weil man eben auf grund der nähe
der schienen störsignale kommt und diese
würden und mögliche bomben anomalien
überdenken
wenn man jetzt mal das ganze
bundesgebiet schaut da liegen ja noch
tausende unentdeckte fliegerbomben aus
dem weltkrieg die nicht hoch gegangen
sind muss man das jetzt so überspitzt
auch sagen es kann eigentlich sein dass
jeder zeit so einer hoch geht ja also
man kann davon ausgehen dass bis zu 20
prozent der abgeworfenen fliegerbomben
nicht detoniert sind
man muss jetzt sehr unterscheiden im
bereich der nicht detonierten bomben
gibt es die sogenannte langzeitzünder
bomben wie sie auch in oranienburg sich
viel abgeworfen sind dort werden die
zinssystem im laufe der zeit unsicherer
das heißt also ihren regierungs elemente
korrodieren oder lösen sich auf und
diese bomben können schon bei geringer
berührung oder erschütterung in
unmittelbaren detonieren es gibt aber
auch den überwiegenden teil der
konventionellen bomben bei denen sind
systeme feste osten war auf deutsch
gesagt
daran da kannten dich sehr viel
passieren wenn man nicht unmittelbar
eine mechanische energie auf dem zünder
einwirkt das heißt also dort muss man
schon mit fragen oder drehenden
bohrverfahren oder rampe fahren direkt
ins hintertreffen dann gehen sie immer
hoch danke man hat den und man hat also
aus notwendigkeit die auslöser eine
übertragungsleitung das tnt selbst ist
nicht so gefährlich und man kann etwa
davon ausgehen dass zwischen fünf und
zehn prozent der bombenblindgänger
diesen hochgefährlichen langzeitzünder
haben danke für ihre einschätzung der
kampfmittelräumer rüdiger schmidt
hierbei bild live nach dieser
schreckensmeldung die uns heute hier am
nachmittag ereilt hat aus münchen dort
also eine weltkriegsbombe heute
hochgegangen bei bauarbeiten und sofort
kam einem bilder von vor rund 10 jahren
in den kopf als nämlich etwas ganz
ähnliches in münchen passierte damals
sollte eine bombe entschärft werden in
schwabing mitten in einem schicken
wohnviertel und plötzlich ging da auch
gewaltig was schief bei dieser ja
kontrollierten sprengung damals es
sollte kontrolliert sein und geriet eben
völlig außer kontrolle eine gewaltige
explosion damals 2012 war das da lag die
bombe schon fast 70 jahre still unter
der erde und dann erschütterte sie in
diesen tagen schwabing es ging damals
fensterscheiben zu bruch ganz schwabing
im grunde wackelte und so ungefähr muss
es eben heute auch gewesen sein dort am
hauptbahnhof er bei dieser gewaltigen
detonation am mittag als eben eine 250
kilo fliegerbombe dort nach so vielen
jahren hochging vier verletzte dass also
die schlimme bilanz heute aus tja wie
keine schöne vorstellung dass noch so
viele von diesen fliegerbomben hier
überall unter uns liegen und jederzeit
explodieren könnten habe es gerade
gehört 20 prozent das finde ich schon
eine ganze menge was für einen beruf für
all die die das räumen also sowie
rüdiger schmidt mahnte vor diesem beruf
gerade nach diesem unfall heute